Thank you all for coming out.
Well,
good evening Dublin.
As you've just heard,
Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris met the
first time in person two weeks ago now
in Vancouver.
They covered an enormous amount of
ground and there is I think,
an enormous amount of ground still to
cover,
but I've asked them if they would start
this evening in the following way.
You're all familiar with a straw
manning.
Anyone who follows politics,
no straw manning,
but I've asked them to do the opposite
tonight,
to start by steel manning the arguments
of each other to present in the best
possible,
most,
most rigorous light,
what they understand to be the other's
argument on all of the meat.
Do issues we're about to discuss.
I'm going to ask Sam Harris to go first
and we're going to go from there.
Thank you.
So first,
thank you all for coming.
It's really,
it's an immense privilege for us to do.
I should say many of you have sacrificed
a lot to come here.
People who have come from other
countries.
I'm told you all dealt with a ticketing
system that seems like it was run from a
cave in Afghanistan.
It's,
um,
so again,
thank you all because it's,
you know,
it's one thing for us to put this date
on the calendar and say we're going to
speak here is another for all of you to
show up.
And this is a privilege we certainly
don't take for granted.
So it's an immense one.
So Jordan and I should say that they'll
much of our conversation together.
Wow.
We'll often sound like we're debating
it.
We will definitely have.
None of us are in the habit of pulling
our punches.
There's an immense amount of goodwill
here and it's true onstage.
It's true offstage and we're all trying
to refine our beliefs together in
conversation.
So this,
wouldn't none of us view this as a
debate though we might stridently
disagree about one thing or another.
Um,
what.
So what Jordan,
I think,
disagrees with me about it.
I think he is worried that I thought,
wow,
we clearly have a common project we're
both concerned to understand how to live
lives worth living.
How can we do this individually and how
can we build societies that safeguard
this project for millions of people
attempting to do this and in their
diverse ways and so,
so many questions immediately come
online when you try to do that,
but what is the relationship between
facts and values,
for instance,
or science and spiritual experience or
ethical lives?
And we have,
as for the moment,
different answers to those westerns.
Jordan is concerned that I,
in my allergy to religion in
sufficiently value the power of stories
in general and religious stories in
particular,
that,
that there's something more than just
nakedly engaging with facts as the,
as they are,
but we do.
We don't simply come into contact with
reality.
We have to interpret reality.
We interpreted through our senses and
with our brands obviously,
but you need frameworks and as Jordan
would say,
stories with which to do that you don't
get facts in the Ra.
And a Jordan believes that I,
because my purpose so often is to
counter what I view as the dangerous
dog.
Most within religion.
I ignore the power and even the
necessity of certain kinds of stories.
Uh,
and certain ways of thinking about the
world and,
and our situation in the world that,
that not only bring many,
many millions or even billions of
people,
immense value are in fact necessary for
anyone.
However rational to build a society
where all of our,
our,
a wellbeing,
uh,
can,
can be conserved.
So I think if,
if in brief that's,
that's Jordan's concerned about me,
okay,
so sam is concerned.
Um,
I would say above all,
with the minimization of unnecessary
suffering,
which seems to me to be a pretty good
place to start and he's concerned that
he's concerned that in order to do that
we need to develop an ethic.
And that ethic should be grounded in
that realization that unnecessary
suffering is worth contending with and
dealing with.
And that and that if we make too much of
the divide between facts and values,
then we end up in a situation where our
value structure has no super subordinate
foundational grounding.
And this is a big problem.
So generally in the philosophical
community,
it's accepted,
although not universally,
that it's difficult if not impossible to
derive value from facts.
But the problem with that proposition is
that you end up in a situation where
either you lose all your values because
they're just arbitrary or you or you
have to ground them in something that
isn't,
that that's revelatory.
And Sam is concerned that one of the
negative consequences of grounding your
fundamental ethic in something that's
revealed is the emergent consequence of
irrational fundamentalism.
And so obviously that's worth contending
with.
And so he's taking issue with the
philosophical idea that facts and values
have to be separate and formulating the
proposition that we can in fact ground a
universal system of values in the facts
and that we can mediate between the
facts and the system of values using
using our facility for truth,
but even more specifically our facility
for rationality and that rationality can
be the mediator between the world of
facts in the world and the world of
values.
And so the problem I have with that,
I guess if,
if we can skip briefly to problems,
is that it isn't obvious to me how to
produce an ethos with sufficient
motivating power to,
to ground that conception of the
minimization of suffering.
Say in the promotion of wellbeing in a
way that's,
that grips people in the United States
society.
And so I think that's,
that's part of what we're discussing and
trying to sort out with regards to the
potential role of narrative and
religious belief as an underpinning to
this ethos.
We seem to agree on the necessity for
the universal ethos.
We even seem to agree,
I would say on what that is because
certainly the minimization of suffering
seems to me to be a very good place to
start.
We share,
um,
our concern with and a belief that the
pathway to that ethos is in some manner
related to our ability to speak the
truth,
but we disagree on what that has to be
grounded in and how it has to be
grounded.
My sense,
especially after thinking about our
discussion is that Sam makes what
rationality is do too much work.
And I'm hoping that not that rationality
is irrelevant or unimportant because it
clearly is neither of those.
But maybe the devil's in the details and
hopefully we can get down to the details
tonight.
And we,
we,
for me,
we brought Douglas into the
conversation.
He's here to serve as much more than a
mere moderator and partly we we've
determined that as Sam alluded to,
that what we're actually trying to
figure out is what are the minimum
necessary preconditions for the
construction of engaged productive
individuals with meaningful,
responsible lives in a society that's
stable enough to sustain itself and
dynamic enough to change what are the
minimal preconditions for that?
What are the and how do we ground those
presuppositions,
those preconditions,
and what price do we pay for for having
them because you never get something
without a cost.
And we thought that Douglas would be
very interesting addition to this
conversation because of course he's
concentrated on such things as borders
and when you set up preconditions for
social order,
you also automatically produced such
things as hierarchies and borders and
they don't come without a cost.
And so we hope to expand the
conversation to include a discussion of
those issues as well.
Yeah.
Before Douglas Chimes,
and I just want to reiterate the fact
that he has not been cast here as our
moderator though.
If Jordan and I run off the rails,
I expect Douglas to put us back on,
and the king's English,
I'm not moderate enough to be a
moderator,
but,
uh,
your,
your more moderate than either of us
are,
but so I want,
I want you to reset the part of your
brain that is poised to begrudge the
moderator taken up too much time because
every moderator has felt that.
And Bret Weinstein was brilliantly aloof
and uninvolved in much of our exchange
together,
but,
but doug was really a third participant
here and,
uh,
and he,
he stands between Jordan and I on some
issues in a interesting way so that
there's a,
we have a three way conversation here
where none of us is really sitting in
the same spot.
So
can I make a quick observation about
some of the,
some of the progress that you've already
made in Vancouver?
Some of the Progress I hope we can make
tonight seems to be.
I see one thing that hampers it,
um,
uh,
let me go straight to it with
sandwiches.
Um,
I discovered a terrific phrase the other
day that our mutual friend,
Eric Weinstein came up with,
were talking about the manner in which
you can discuss within the sciences
certain scientific problems.
And he said,
look,
if you've got a scientist who you know
is also basically a very literalist
Christian,
you will listen to their argument a
whole long part of the way and there's
somewhere at the end of it,
you know,
you're going to be worried about it.
And he came up with this phrase,
I love this face.
He says,
Jesus smuggling,
right?
Jesus smuggling is,
you're going to follow all the way.
Yes.
And then the worry is that when you get
to the bit that you're not so good on,
that's when they're going to smuggle in
Jesus.
Yeah.
Um,
my suspicion is that you have a
reservation about some of what Jordan is
saying on the substructures on stories
and much more because you're worried
that at some point,
either on stage or off it at some point
when you're not looking.
No,
no.
When I am looking to Jesus.
Smuggle you.
Yeah.
I was thinking maybe I just carry them
in on a cross.
Well,
that isn't all to apt analogy because
it's a.
It is what worries me and it's but it's.
It's more subtle than that because it's
not.
Just to think that you're consciously
doing it.
Is is a different claim that like
there's a.
I don't think there's anything insincere
about your argument for the,
for the importance of religion,
but it's.
It's also possible we've all met the
people who we believe are making the of
arguments and are really there.
They're consciously putting the rabbit
in the hat and then it pretending to be
surprised when it pops out.
Right,
and it the analogy that magic is
actually interesting here because we had
you.
We had over dinner,
we're talking about the,
the,
the difference between real and fake art
and we were talking about this parent,
this paradox that the art seems to be
incredibly valuable and yet the value
isn't located in the object itself or
can't be obviously located there because
a forgery that is a materially the exact
copy of some masterpiece is essentially
worthless and the real masterpiece.
Even if it suffered some damage would be
incredibly valuable and so where is the
value to be located?
But it worries me about your enterprise
Jordan and the way in which you were you
were.
You seem to be linking our rational
project and our scientific project with
religion is,
is right here.
There's A.
There's a difference between at map
magic as a decent analogy.
There's a difference between like
paradoxically real magic is fake magic
and fake magic is real magic.
The real magic in the world produced by
magicians is the fake magic where the
magician,
like someone like Darren Brown will tell
you.
Actually no,
I can't read minds and I,
I did put the rabbit in the hat and if
this is fake,
but,
but the,
the surprise is that even knowing it's
fake,
you can't understand how this affect is
being achieved.
Whereas the fake magicians are the ones
who are pretending to be real,
who are,
who are hiding,
who are not acknowledging the mechanics,
the real mechanics behind what is in
fact effective.
You know,
the,
the illusion that the rabbit pops out of
the hat.
And what I worry with,
with some of your,
the way in which you discuss the power
story,
the power of metaphor and the religious
anchoring there is that the,
the leverage and the utility can be had
even while acknowledging the real
mechanics of it,
you know,
the fake the fakeness of the magic.
Right?
And you seem to suspect that it can do
that.
Takes all of the wind out of the sales.
I'm not so sure.
I'm not so sure what of it's fake.
And what if it isn't.
Well,
let,
let.
So I would say that I do consciously
participate in the process that you
described,
but,
but you see,
I would also make the case,
and this is certainly one of the things
that we've been,
we've been discussing that you do it
unconsciously and let,
let me make the case for that from him
because I'd really,
I've been thinking about it a lot and
I'd like to see your response.
So here's what I really read the moral
landscape a lot and I thought about it a
lot,
you know,
and so this is what it looks like to me.
So you,
you,
you make the proposition that we have to
breach the gap between facts and values
because otherwise our values are left
hanging unmoored and that certainly
brings about the danger of nihilism,
but also a potential danger of swing to
totalitarianism.
Something we agree about,
right?
I,
I truly do believe that.
And then you perform an operation,
not conceptual operation and you say,
surely we can all agree that.
And then you outline a story about this
woman who lives in this horrible country
who's basically just being starved in
disease ridden and tortured her whole
life and having just a hell of a time of
it to put it in a phrase and then you
say,
well surely we can all agree that that's
not good.
And then you contrast that with,
at least in principle,
the sort of life that we would all like
to have.
If we could choose the life that we
have.
And then you say,
well,
we could start with the proposition that
we should move away from this,
this terrible,
hellish circumstance and we should move
towards this more ideal perspective.
And you say,
if we could only agree on that then and
so and so,
so far so good.
But this is,
this is.
There's a couple of things that go along
with that that are quite interesting.
And so the first is that actually what
you're claiming is that the highest
moral good isn't existing in that better
space.
The highest moral good is acting in the
manner that moves us from the hellish
domain to the desirable domain.
It seems to me to be implicit in your
argument.
So there's a pattern of behavior that
constitutes the ethic.
Well,
I would say existing in that,
in that better space is good enough as
well.
Does that mean that there's the,
there's the question of what it takes to
move from where you are to some place
better and then there's just the
someplace that's better.
There's both of them well
but,
but we perhaps we could say,
look,
what's the ultimate hell?
It might be existing in the hell that
you described,
but it also might be this is something
worse.
I think.
I think that participating in the
process that brings about that hell is
actually a,
that's even deeper than the hell,
so it's an analogous argument.
There's the state of being in a good
state,
but there's also the state of being that
brings you to that good state and then
there's the state of being that's in a.
that's a terrible state and the process
that brings you to that terrible state,
and one of the things that I've learned
from the architectural and religious
texts that I've studied as well as the
philosophical texts is that the process
that transforms society into something
approximating hell is a lower hell.
Now the reasonable.
Let me just close the loop on that
because I'm pretty sure I disagree.
You can imagine to counterexamples one,
as you could imagine,
a statistic being a.
You might even call him God,
who would create a circumstance of hell
and populate it with innocent souls.
Right now that's presumably that action
need not be attended by a lot of
suffering or you could imagine.
No,
but it's still.
It's still wrong.
Totally wrong.
No.
You could even imagine someone who
enjoys generating.
Yes,
it could be a source of even more wrong
than not enjoy it.
Okay,
so.
So we want to separate out two things.
We want to separate out these states of
being and the process that brings them
into being,
and I do believe you do that in your
work because basically what you suggest
is that the appropriate way to act
ethically is to act in a manner that
moves us away from hell and moves us
towards a desirable state.
Now,
the thing is is that as far as I'm
concerned,
there's a couple of things about that.
The first thing is that I wouldn't say
that that mode of acting is a fact.
I would say it's a personality and that
what you're suggesting is that people
embodied the personality that Moves
Society Way from hell towards heaven for
lack of a better term.
And the reason terms and the reason I
make that argument is because I think
that you recapitulate the essential
Christian message precisely by doing
that because symbolically speaking,
at least as far as I can understand,
stripped of its religious con of it's
metaphysical context.
Let's say that the purpose of positing
the,
the vision of the ideal human being,
which independent of the metaphysical
context,
it certainly what the symbol of Christ
represents is the mode of being that
moves us most effectively from something
approximating held to something
approximating heaven and then part of
that part of that message is,
and this is also something that's dead
along the lines of what you're arguing,
is that the best way to embody that is
actually to live in truth.
I mean so because I would say that the
fundamental Christian ethic,
metaphysics accepted once again is to
act in love,
which is to assume that being is
acceptable and can be perfected and to
pursue that with truth and that you
should embody that.
And then I would say that the purpose of
the representation we could call the
mega fictions are archetypal
representations,
is to show that in embodied format so
that it can be imitated rather than to
transform into something that's diluted
in some sense to to an abstract
rationality.
Because I don't think the abstract
rationality in itself has enough flesh
on it so to speak.
Which is partly why in the Christian
ethic,
there's an emphasis that the word which
is something roughly akin to
rationality,
has to make,
has to be made flesh.
It has to be enacted,
but is the.
Is the flesh made of dogmatism and
superstition and other worldliness?
Is that part of what gives it its shape
and necessity?
I think traditionally historically it
has been,
and that's been the problem with
religion.
If you,
if you denude it,
of everything that is unjustifiable and
the light of 21st century science and
rationality,
I think what you have to get down to is
something quite a bit more universal and
less provincial than any specific
religion and Christianity per se.
Well,
it's interesting too though,
you know,
one of the.
One of the things,
one of the points that you do make is
that you do appeal to or assume the
existence of a transcendental internal
ethics.
Something like that.
Which I would say,
by the way,
since we're going down this direction,
seems to me to be something very akin to
the idea of the Holy Spirit,
which is something like the internal
representation of a transcendent
universal ethic.
Now remember,
I'm trying to strip these concepts of
their metaphysical substrate.
I'm not making a case at the moment for
the existence of the great man in the
sky.
We can.
We can get to that later.
I'm saying that what seems to be the
case is that we have underneath our
cognitive architecture and our social
architecture a layer of symbolic and
dramatic narrative representation that
instantiates the same concepts but but
in a,
in a multidimensional context.
One of the things we talked about in
Vancouver for example,
is that the religious enterprise doesn't
only emphasize rationality it.
It brings music into the play and it
brings art into the play and it brings
drama and it brings literature and it
brings architecture and it brings the
organizing of of cities around a central
space like it.
It's,
it's pushing itself.
It's manifesting itself across multiple
dimensions of human existence
simultaneously.
And to me that gives it a richness that
cannot be diluted without loss and and,
and also a motive power that,
that appear appeal to rationality I
don't think can manage,
and this is c,
one of the things and this is maybe a
good place for Douglas,
delete B and c,
what?
One of the things that Douglas,
who's claimed upon multiple locations to
be an atheist and I don't know how he's
feeling about that and at the present
time,
but it doesn't matter if one of the
things.
One of the things Doug Douglas has has
pointed out was that there are things
that we've done in free countries,
let's say broadly speaking in the West
that are worth protecting
and that in order to protect them in the
longest sense,
it's conceivable that we need a,
a,
a cognitive structure.
Something like that that can act as a
bulwark against those forces that would
seek to undermine and destroy it.
And Douglas has been driven,
I would say to some degree,
to hypothesize that for Christianity,
for all its faults,
or we could say Judeo Christianity to
broaden it for all its faults might
provide something approximating that
bowl work if we could only figure out
how to utilize it properly.
So
yes,
I mean one of my problems on this is
that it seems that we are where we are
with belief in whether we wish it to be
or not.
We cannot believe as our predecessors
believed,
even if we wanted to.
We know too much more now and it puts us
in this very difficult position.
But to denude also as if the entire
story seems to me to be a fool's errand
for the set of reasons.
One of which is that from a lot of
travel,
a lot of speaking to people from all
around the well,
it doesn't seem at all obvious to me
that what we have in countries like this
one is the default position of human
beings.
In fact,
it's likes me as being very rare order,
even political order,
political liberalism,
political freedom.
Very,
very unusual things.
And if you like the things that helped
to get through that with all of the
caveats,
with all the caveats we can,
we could fau in all evening and it's not
the only thing that got us there
obviously.
But if you'd like broadly speaking,
where we are,
you've got to be very suspicious at the
very least of saying the whole story is
no good.
We don't need the story.
We can move on.
I quote,
I'm quite often the radical theologian
Don Cupitt,
who was often described as an atheist
priest and cupid.
So somewhere in a recent book he said,
you know,
we can't help it.
He said,
for instance,
the dreams that we dream is still
Christian dreams.
Whether we like that fact or not,
and without being able to believe
myself.
Does that mean not being able to be a
literal believer?
I worry.
I worry about what happens when the
square is denuded completely.
And that's why this discussion tonight
and Youtube in particular are right on
the cusp of this because this is.
This is where I think a lot of us are.
Even if we really wanted to believe,
we basically can't apply that we very
quickly.
That's why I think there's an additional
just to refine my previous point to use
them.
That's why there's this additional
thing.
I think there is a fear which you may
have,
which I also have,
which is if there's a risk that even
what I've just said,
nevermind what Jordan has also say
there's a risk.
I think some people feel that your going
to soften up the somehow and that even
if neither Jordan nor I are going to
suddenly start Jesus smuggling,
we might create the conditions that make
it easier for someone else to do that.
Yeah.
Is that a fair?
Yeah,
and it it.
It is.
No photos.
It's very frustrating,
so thank you.
Let me see if I can sharpen up what my
concern actually is here because it's
not even true to say that I think you
need to get rid of the Jesus story or
even or even not.
Hey,
I'd be.
I don't even think there's something
problematic with orienting your life
around the Jesus Story.
I think that that can be reclaimed,
but so for instance,
I was walking yesterday in this fine
city of yours and saw someone on the
sidewalk giving Taro readings to people
he had with a Taro deck spread out.
He had a few cards spread out and he was
soliciting people.
And,
and,
uh,
I'm sorry to say I didn't sit for a
reading,
but to Tarot cards,
if you're familiar with them,
are the quintessential artifact of new
age woo,
right?
Um,
there,
these are not thought of as legitimate
tools of divination except by people who
think that they're legitimate tools of
divination.
And yet a tarot reading can be truly
powerful,
right?
I mean,
this is built on something,
right?
This is not just a massive,
uh,
example of self deception on the part of
people reading and people getting their
cards read it.
These cards can seem pressured.
I could give you all are reading right
now and 95 percent of you would find
what I would,
what the cards would say to be relevant
to your lives.
I mean,
I could do it with an imaginary deck.
I don't even I in invisible imaginary
deck,
I don't know anything about Tarot cards,
but I'm going to turn over to cards now.
One is the son and the other is the
fallen man.
Now I know so little about Taro than I'm
not even sure the fallen man is a
terrible part or I think it was the
hanged man isn't terrible.
Okay,
so I've got these two cards and you know
the sun is clearly the representation of
wisdom,
right?
And the and the.
The hanged man is the is the
representation of,
of lost opportunity.
And I can tell you with some degree of
certainty that all of you are at a
crossroads in your life where you have,
you have good reason to believe that
you're not making the most of your
opportunities right now.
I could go on like this for an hour and
pretend all the wild that it has
something to do with the car.
It's actually been working in concert
with the dynamics of the cosmos such
that these cards that I turn over,
were they real,
would be the ones that Dave of
necessity.
When revealing something about your mind
in this moment and obviously people
think in these terms about astrology and
sympathetic magic and all the rest and
religion is built upon this kind of
superstition,
there is a way of understanding the
utility of using a device like this and
the real effect it has on you.
I mean if I turn over the cards and ask
you to look at your life in this moment
as though for the first time through
this lens,
considering in this case lost
opportunities,
right?
Of course it's going to be valid.
That doesn't make.
It could be an incredibly useful thing
to do.
The My.
My main concern is that at no point you
have to lie to yourself about your state
of knowledge about the mechanism,
right?
You don't have to believe Taro cards
really.
There's deeper,
deeper mechanisms at work with someone
who's actually good at that and so I
agree with what you said,
but they need not be super nice.
No,
I don't think they are supernatural and
in fact I think what happens when you
use a projective technique like that
because that's essentially what it is.
If I'm good at interpersonal attunement
and I'm quite intuitive what I'm going
to do this and everyone does this in the
course of a dialogue that's actually
working well,
I'm going to flip over the cards and I'm
going to start with generic archetipal
statements that are,
that are true in some sense for
everyone,
but then I'm going to watch you both
consciously and implicitly,
unconsciously with all of my social
intelligence and I'm going to see
through very,
very subtle signs on your part when you
respond positively to what I'm saying
and when you respond negatively,
and I'm going to continue down the lines
that you established by your positive
responses.
Brown does.
He's a mentalist,
right?
Well,
it's exactly what happens when children
are interviewed,
for example,
by people who lead them as witnesses,
right?
The children infer from the emotional
expressions of the person who's
interrogating them what it is that they
actually want to hear,
and so they'll have even worked with
that horse.
Clever Hans.
Exactly.
That's right.
Even horses can do this,
so carol card readers can definitely do
this.
So,
so,
so the mechanisms behind something like
that,
even if it appears entirely
superstitious on the surface,
are often deeper than it is revealed at
first approximation.
So,
and I wanted to talk a little bit,
if you don't mind,
for a minute about rationality because
the,
we've already agreed,
I think definitely stop me if I'm wrong,
that there has to be an intermediary
mechanism between the world of facts in
the world of values.
And well,
since we've talked,
I've been reading a variety of
commentaries on Emmanuel Kant.
Mostly these are been written by Roger
Scruton by the way,
and this is actually the issue that they
can't,
um,
what obsessed about for most of his
philosophical life.
And what he concluded was that
empiricism can't be right in
rationality,
can't be right as philosophical
disciplines because you need an
intermediary structure that we have an
inbuilt intermediary structure.
And that structure is what mediates
between the thing in itself.
The world of facts,
let's say,
and the outputs,
the values.
So then I was thinking
the truth is we don't quite agree on
this in my summary of your view of me.
I would have agreed with that,
but for me it's just facts all the way
down.
One cares.
You're great.
You're describing glad.
Glad to hear it,
man.
Why do you need a brain then?
Well,
but brandon is yet another part of
reality.
And what I mean by a fact,
do anything there.
What does the brain do?
It has to do something because otherwise
you don't need it.
Sure,
it does a lot.
But the,
the uh,
so your concern,
I did it to jump to the other,
where I think we're going in this
conversation is how is it that values
can be another order of fact that seems
problematic to you.
It seems problematic.
It's problematic to David Hume.
Well,
it's problematic for me for technical
reasons,
which is that in order to app and we see
if we agree on this in order to perceive
and to act,
which I believe are both acts of value,
to perceive as an active value because
you have to look at something instead of
a bunch of other things,
so you have you elevate the thing that
you're perceiving to the position of
highest value by perceiving it,
by deciding to perceive it.
Okay.
That gets translated in my brain into
just more facts.
You're just giving me the facts of human
perception.
That's fine.
No,
that's no problem.
I'm perfectly happy about that.
And then in order to act,
you have to select the target of action
from among an infinite number near
infinite number,
close enough of possible mechanisms of
action.
And so what a biological organism does
is take the facts and translate them
into perception and action.
And the only organisms that do that with
one to one mapping are organisms that
are composed of sensory motor cells,
like sponges,
marine sponges,
which are composed of sensory motor
cells.
They don't have an intermediary nervous
system,
so what they do is they sit in the water
and they make a sponge.
They're so simple that if you grind a
sponge through a sieve and in salt
water,
it'll reorganize itself into the sponge,
so that's quite cool.
The sponge sits in the water.
Don't do that,
and what it does,
what
it does is it there's waves on it and so
it.
Those are patterns and then the sponge
opens and closes,
pours on its surface in response to
those patterns.
So it maps the pattern of the waves
right onto its behavior with no
intermediary of a nervous system,
but it can only map waves.
That's all it can do,
and it can only open and close pores.
That's it.
So it does one to one factor value
mapping.
Now what happens is that as the,
as the complexity of a biological
organism increases,
two things happen.
The first thing that happens is that the
sensory and motor cells differentiate.
So now the organism has sensory cells
and motorcycle.
So since senses to detect and census,
sorry,
cells to detect and cells to act.
Okay?
So then it can do,
it can detect more patterns because it's
more sophisticated at the sensory port
perspective and it could do more things
because it has specialized motor
systems,
but then what happens is that as it gets
even more complex,
then it puts an intermediary structure
of nervous tissue in there and that
structure increases in the number of
layers of neurons.
And what that means is that as soon as
that happens and as the sensory cells
become more specialized and as the motor
output cells become more specialized,
many more patterns can be detected.
Those are roughly equivalent to facts
and many more motor outputs can be
manifested,
but a tremendous number of calculations
have to has to occur in that
intermediary nervous tissue.
And that's the structure that I'm
talking about.
That structure exists and it translates
the patterns into motor output and it
doesn't do it on a one to one basis
because there are more patterns,
more facts.
Then there are motor outputs.
So what has to happen is this tremendous
plethora of facts that surrounds us has
to be filtered to the point where you
pick a single action because you can't
act,
act otherwise,
and so the mechanism that reduces the
number of facts to the selected action
is the mechanism that mediates between
facts and values.
And it's not simply in and of itself.
It's a fact that that exists.
But it isn't a simple that what it does
isn't the simple fact you can't do.
You can't explain it.
You can't understand it.
Why not?
For the same reason that you can't look
for the same reason,
for the same reason that you don't know
what a neural network is doing,
like you can train a neural network and
network.
There's
a distinction between facts and facts
that we know right there.
There is whatever it is the case,
right?
And then there's our understanding of it
and our misunderstanding of it.
So there are many things that we think
we know that we're wrong about.
There are many things that we are aware
we're ignorant of and there's this,
there's this larger always this larger
space of reality that we're struggling
to engage with and it may in fact be the
case that in evolutionary terms,
but we know it's the case that we're.
We have not evolved to understand large
perfectly.
That's not the sort of monkeys we are.
Right,
and you could even argue that one,
one cognitive scientist who some of you
may have heard of Donald Hoffman is
arguing now know very colorfully that
human consciousness or the human mind
is,
is actually evolved to get things wrong
in a fairly specific ways so that so as
to maximize survival.
And that was the argument I made in our
first discussion.
No,
but,
but here was not quite because there's
still.
This still preserves the difference
between getting things right and getting
things wrong.
He,
his,
his argument is that getting things
truly right,
having a nervous system and a cognitive
architecture that could really
understand reality quote reality as it
is,
would be maladaptive and he has some.
He has some mathematical demonstration
of this that,
that,
that the,
the true,
the quote,
true representations of reality are
categorically maladaptive and you had
that there's certain kind of error that
is,
and I'm not,
I'm not sure I buy this argument,
but the fact that you can make this
argument,
the fact that you can differentiate the
adaptively useful misunderstandings
versus a true understanding,
that it's maladaptive.
The fact that we can even talk about
that demonstrates to me that we have
this larger picture of what is in fact
true whether we know it or not,
and this is what this is what religion
get so catastrophic.
The wrong religion gives you some other
mechanism whereby,
whereby to Orient Yourself in this case
revelation,
does religion does provide those,
those functional simplifications
actually a similar purpose.
There are simplifications appropriate to
the Iron Age?
Well,
some of that,
some of them are for sure,
and that's why we have to have this
discussion because,
because mirror,
mirror revelation in mere tradition is
insufficient.
And I,
I truly believe that we can agree on
that.
But back to the back to the biological
argument.
So,
um,
because I thought that tonight I would
make a very strictly biological argument
is that so now the question is now,
so now you've got your sensory systems
that are detecting the world of facts
and you have your motor output system,
which is a very narrow channel because
you can only do one thing at a time.
And that's one of the things about
consciousness that's quite strange.
It's a very,
very narrow channel.
So you have to take this unbelievably
complex world and you have to channel it
into this very narrow channel and you,
you don't do that by being wrong about
the world,
but you do do that by ignoring a lot of
the world and by using representations
that are no more complicated than they
have to be in order to attain the task
at hand.
It's like you're losing using low
resolution representations of the world.
They're not inaccurate because a low
resolution representations of the world
isn't inaccurate any more than a low
resolution photo is.
But there are no resolution than they
need to be in order for you to undertake
the task at hand.
And if you undertake the task at hand
and that goes successfully,
then what you've done,
and this is basically the essence of
American pragmatism,
what you've done is validated the you've
validated the validity of your
simplifications.
So if the tool you have in hand is good,
if the ax you have in hand is sharp
enough to chop down the tree,
that it's a good enough acts and that's
part of the way that we define truth
pragmatically in the absence of infinite
knowledge about everything.
Okay?
So now you build up this nervous system
between the world of facts and the world
of values and it,
and it narrows the world of facts.
And the question then is how do you
generate the mechanism that does that
narrowing?
And this is what's useful.
That's not quite how the cake is
layered.
What the facts are up here to write
right?
For me to,
for me to even notice that you're a
person,
right?
Or to attribute beliefs to you or to
have a sense of being in relationship at
all.
This is one of those higher order
interpretive acts based on a many
layered nervous system.
Yes,
it's not only bought them up yet,
but yeah,
it's bottom up and top down.
Yes and and,
but fat.
But facts are also on the top,
right?
It's not that we have facts here and
values here.
It's,
it's,
well,
I think what I'm trying to do,
I can't get to a fag,
but through going to do.
I think maybe one way of thinking about
it,
just that you,
you are using your positing that we can
use rationality as a mechanism for
mediating between facts and values,
I believe because otherwise there's no
use for rationality.
We can just have the facts.
So it's a process even simpler than
that.
It's just that for me and I think for
everyone,
if they will only agree to use language
in this way.
For me values are simply facts about the
experience of conscious creatures.
Good at that experiences give us our
values.
Yeah,
but they're not simple,
but at there are the goods in the
summer.
Very simple.
You have in your hand,
put it on a hot stove is incredibly
simple and you'll notice it'll save your
child if you do it well.
But again,
the unpleasantness of it.
Right now it's an orthogonal.
No,
it's not.
If you look at the way the reward and
punishment systems work in the brain,
you can easily train an animal using
reward to wag its tail.
If it's being shocked electrically,
you can do that and you can wire it very
loaded.
There's a range of unpleasant
experiences we can have where we can
construe them as pleasant or
unnecessary.
Right?
And that's a kind of a higher level of
theater.
But I'm talking about,
you know,
the worst possible sensory experience
that all of us will agree,
we'll agree is unpleasant,
right?
That doesn't require a story too for us
to feel a version two.
And there's,
there are many things like that in life
that are just just rudimentary where
it's just we are,
we are organized in such a way that
put put us into fire.
We don't like it.
So are you clear?
Are you claiming then like this is
another problem.
This is where I think that the argument
that you make,
although accurate in its rudiments,
let's say,
is insufficiently high resolution
because now it sounds to me like you're
including the domain of quality
unquestioningly in the domain of facts.
Now you can do that,
but we need to know if that's what
you're doing.
Like what are these facts you're talking
about?
Are they mirrored manifestations of the
objective world or do they shade into
the subject?
There
are,
there are objective facts about
subjective experience,
so I can make,
I can make true or false claims about
your subjectivity and that you can make.
You can make those about your,
your own subjectivity,
right?
You can be wrong about your own
subjectivity.
You're,
we're not subjectively encourageable.
Uh,
and I,
I might've said this last time in
Vancouver.
I mean,
the example I often use here is to
speculate about what jfk was thinking.
The moment he got shot right is not a,
a completely vacuous exercise there.
They're literally an infinite number of
things we know he wasn't thinking right?
So we can make claims about his
conscious mind at,
at,
at that moment in history,
which are scientific a,
even though the data are unavailable,
right?
So many people get confused between
having an answers and practice and
there'd be an answers and principle.
I mean,
there,
there are many trivial fact based claims
we could make about reality where we
can't get the data,
but we know the data are there.
So,
you know,
do you have an even or odd number of
hairs on your body at this moment?
You know,
we,
you know,
we don't want to think about what it
would take to ascertain that fact,
right?
But there is a fact of the matter,
And uh,
and so it is with anything but.
So what is somebody,
what does a person way?
There's many,
many facts are blurry because you are
going to weigh,
weigh him down to the,
the 100th decimal plate place.
No.
So it's like at a certain point you are
going to be rounding and someone's
weight at that point is changing every
microsecond because they're exchanging
adams with the air.
So there's.
So there,
there are facts that can be loosely
defined.
Uh,
this is still,
this is true of all of our subjective
lives too.
So if it is a fact about you that when
you,
when you were praying to Jesus,
you felt an upwelling of rapture,
right?
Subjectively,
that can be an absolutely true thing to
say about you.
We can,
we can pair that subject of experience
with an understanding of,
of the neurophysiological basis for it.
Uh,
you can think about it in terms of a
larger story about your life,
but all of this can be translated into a
fact based discussion about what's
happening for you.
And my only claim is that,
that the value part,
and hence the ethics part relates to
the,
the extremes of positive and negative
experience that people have
not.
First of all,
I wouldn't dispute.
I don't want to dispute the fact that
there are stable quality of pain and
pleasure,
for example.
And also that there are fundamental
motivational systems that structure our
perception.
So as the nervous system increases in
complexity,
these underlying nervous system
subsections that produce these rather
stable quality,
uh,
evolve,
hunger,
thirst,
defensive aggression,
sexuality,
all these subsystems that,
that,
that label experience with certain
somewhat inviolable labels.
I understand that happens.
But the point that I'm trying to make
here is I think to try to increase the,
what would you call the breadth of the
conversation about how facts get
translated into,
into values?
Because it seems to me the other thing
that your account doesn't take proper.
And this is what surprised me so much
about your thinking when I first
encountered it.
See,
I think the manner in which facts are
translated into values is something that
actually evolved.
And it evolved over three and a half
billion years.
The three and a half billion years of
life.
And it built the nervous system from the
bottom up and it built this reducing
mechanism that takes the infinite number
of facts and translates them into a
single value per action.
And it does that in layers.
And so there is a relationship between
the world of facts in the world of
values.
And there has to be,
but it isn't derival one to one in the
confines of your single existence
through pure rationality.
It's way more complicated than that
if there's more to it than rationality.
Again,
it's not rationality that causes you to
remove your hand from a hot stove and
like the experience of love and bliss
and rapture and creativity over or more
than pointless misery and despair.
Right?
So like things other than rationality
are clearly necessary.
Absolutely.
But the question is,
do we ever have to be irrational to get
the good things in life?
And I would argue that,
that the answer to that clearly no,
there's nothing irrational about loving
your wife or your best friend or
yourself or even a stranger if,
if,
if what you mean by love there is
genuinely wanting happiness for that
person,
genuinely taken pleasure in their
company,
genuinely wanting to,
to find a way of being where you're,
you're no longer in a zero sum condition
with a stranger or with a partner,
but you're,
you're,
uh,
collaborating together to have better
lives.
Seems rationality moves through that
situation continuously because
rationality is the only way that you and
I can get our representations of the
world to cohere.
It's,
it's when I say,
okay,
there's,
there's a lion behind that rock.
Don't go over there that only that only
makes sense to you if you're playing
this rationality game it the way I'm
planted.
If I mean something else by lion or I
mean something else by don't go over
there.
You know,
you're confused and,
and very likely did or not.
If we're,
if we're trying to establish the
proposition that rationality is the
mechanism by which we make our
worldviews cohere,
I would agree with that in part,
we also will make them cohere because
we're actually biologically structured
the same way.
And so there's a proclivity for them to
go here to begin with,
but we iron out our differences through
the exercise.
I wouldn't call it rationality.
I would call it logos because I think
it's a more,
it's a broader
were you smuggling energy's not
unconscious of that.
Let's say as a point of order here,
I want to,
uh,
I'm a,
I'm a disconcerted by Douglas is
silence.
I want to pivot because I know,
I know how good he is when he actually
speaks.
Uh,
so I want to pivot to another subject
because we can return to this at some
point we need to have before you pivot.
So yeah,
go for it.
I mean,
having said to you what I think your
concern is with Jordan,
Jordan's concerned,
and I share this just as I share some of
your concerns expressed at the outset,
Jordan's fundamental concern.
It seems to me as a one I fundamentally
share,
which is rationalism isn't enough and
it's
put it another way,
but then let me finish.
Can you both show me where it,
where it's obviously insufficient like
music,
but there's nothing but.
But again,
so to say that it's not to say that
there's more to life than being rational
is not to say and perhaps never to say
you need to run against rationality.
Need to be irrational in order to get
something good.
Let me,
let me express it a different way.
Yeah,
we haven't tried the purely rational
approach yet.
We haven't tried it for very long,
well,
many,
many of us had been trying for a couple
of centuries at least,
which is a blip.
I mean the tiniest.at
the end of human evolution.
So I think that a concern which Jordan
hasn't said,
any concern I have is if we try this,
we can think of all sorts of ways in
which you can go wrong if you take away
all the supporting structure can think
of any number of ways in which you can
go wrong and that I suppose that that's
at the root of the concern about where
you might be taking us or to put it
another way,
if we enter the world that you would
suggest not everyone may not necessarily
come out as Sam Harris.
Okay.
Give me one way where you think it can
go wrong.
And again,
we can't forget your caveat which you
started with.
What if you're not very smart,
right?
Well,
the person.
So then you're basically saying that the
stupid people need their myths.
We smart people onstage don't need that.
Right?
Well,
I am actually,
I'm looked,
I actually am saying that to some degree
that this look,
look,
if you're,
if you're not exceptionally cognitively
astute,
you should be traditional and
conservative because if you are,
if you can't think,
well,
you're going to think badly and if you
think badly,
you're going to fall into trouble and so
it is definitely the case and this has
been an what would you call a cliche of
political belief for a long time.
If you're not very smart,
it's better to be conservative because
then you do what everyone else does and
generally speaking,
doing what everyone else does is the
path of least error moving forward.
Now,
that doesn't mean that rationality is
unnecessary.
It doesn't mean that old conservatives
astute,
headless.
It doesn't mean that either,
right?
Precisely.
It doesn't mean that Kevin,
but,
but all can,
all conservative structures are not the
same either and that we have many
warring and incompatible versions of
being conservative.
True,
true,
and this is exactly,
this is where rationality actually does
play a role.
Although I don't think it's best
conceptualized as rationality,
precisely.
It's definitely the case that we tend to
take douglass point that we need to be
bound by our traditions,
but we need to be judicious in their
representation and update and we have to
do both
the dialogue on religion.
This is what he says.
He says,
he describes the tragedy of the clergy.
He pretty much,
he pretty much says,
look,
if they don't believe it,
they recognize it's a very useful
metaphor,
but they don't need to believe it.
It's they tell it and he says the
tragedy of the clergy is they can never
admit that what they're saying is just a
metaphor.
Right?
So just before or after he threw his
housekeeper down the stairs,
look,
we can all find flaws.
We all have skeletons in our closet.
Yeah.
Um,
but the,
the,
there is a way in which religion is what
he describes his philosophy for the
masses and that if you recognize that
most people are not gonna spend their
lives studying philosophy,
they're not going to be reading about
the differences between live Nixon comp
that religion has to do.
Now,
I'm not saying that I agree with that
particularly,
but there's a heck of an argument within
the which a lot of people will be living
their lives in.
I don't think it's a good argument if
you recall or I just imagine what it's
like to be a child,
especially from the perspective of being
a parent.
I have two young girls and they,
you know,
they're very smart young girl.
They're smart,
but you know,
one of them is four and a half years old
and those almost nothing.
Right?
So she knows what I and my wife and our
society tell her at some level.
I mean,
at what point is she going to think for
herself about these fundamental
questions?
And I mean she again,
she's,
she's currently spending half the day
dressed up like batgirl or cat woman.
Right?
So if I told her that these superheroes
were real,
she would believe that for the longest
time and if she,
if we lived in a cult that thought they
were real or a whole society that by
dint of its geographic or linguistic
isolation managed to maintain a
conversation about,
in this case batgirl and catwoman,
that they were real and that it was
absolutely important to honor them and
you'd burn in hell if you fail to do
this,
but this would be.
We would be meeting fully grown adults
who believed this sort of thing,
but it seems to me,
Sam,
that you bring up the superhero thing
quite a bit.
So I think I'll go to that directly so
that I want.
I love superheroes so well.
So.
So
you make the case in a moral landscape
that they're an ideal is real because
the ideal that you define an ideal is
real and the ideal is whatever.
Maximize wellbeing and gets us away from
hell.
You said not only is that real,
you also say that's the fundamental
axiom.
That's the claim in the moral landscape.
So you do make a claim that there is a
real ideal,
and
I wouldn't necessarily put it that way,
but there's a real.
We are in a circumstance where things
can't matter,
right?
We consciousness is the key is the
condition in which things can matter,
where there can be a range of
experiences,
some of which are very,
very bad.
If the word bad means anything,
they're bad and some of which are very,
very good.
If the,
if the word good means anything and we
are navigating in that space,
we can't help it navigate it or seek to
navigate in that space.
And religion is one.
Okay,
we'll look more of a conversation.
That navigation problem and I would
argue and go back to the idea that
diluted one like Jordan rose
sleeves up that girl,
we mean business now,
but that girl in cat woman are
approximations to a higher ideal.
That's what they are.
And and do attendance with a biblical
idea.
I'm,
I'm fairly sure if person there are a
lot of parents are perfectly content
with bringing their children up vaguely
within the story they've inherited and
at some point the children realize that
the fairy doesn't bring them money when
their teeth fall out and at some point
maybe around the same time or a bit
later,
they discovered the Santa Claus doesn't
really come down the chimney and at some
point they realized that actually the
whole religious thing is a kind of
metaphor,
but he's got them through the formative
years in some way,
often with terrible damage along the
way.
I can see that,
but also with something else,
and I'm.
I'm struck by the number of people,
and this is why I share some of what I
think is Jordan's concerned about the
possibility of the world.
You're envisaging,
which is I can think of a lot of parents
now,
my country and other countries as well
who I'm just very struck.
They themselves a kind of baby boomer or
sixties atheists,
humanists,
whatever,
and I start to notice,
for instance,
that they're enrolling their children in
Christian schools and I saved them.
Why are you doing this?
And they have fairly coherent arguments
along the way with the lines.
That one I just had,
look,
I don't particularly believe this
myself,
but I think it's a pretty good way to
bring up the kids.
It's the structure of a kind and I'm not
sure I can find all sorts of flaws in
that,
but enough people are doing it that it's
something that needs to be addressed.
What I would.
It's I would say yes,
it speaks to a real failure of
imagination and an effort in the secular
community to produce truly non
embarrassing alternative.
Exactly.
And,
and this is,
this is across the board.
This is not just school,
this is how do you conduct a funeral?
How do you get married,
you know,
all of the it.
What rites of passage can you offer a 13
year old
doing here?
What are we doing to have,
how to have the first people in history
to have absolutely no explanation for
what we're doing at all.
Yeah.
It is a big moment.
Yes.
And that's the noise that sharpens up my
concern perfectly,
because to to shrink back from that
moment and resort to one of the,
the pseudo stories of the past,
I consider it to be a failure of nerve,
both,
both intellectually and morally.
Okay.
So let,
let's go back to the,
to the
hero idea.
One of the,
one of the things you might notice about
superheroes is that some of them are
actually Dante's right?
So in the Marvel Pantheon you have thor
for example,
and so there's a,
there's a very thin line between the
idea of the superhero and the idea of a
god,
especially if you think about it in a
polytheistic manner.
So the modern superheroes and the Greek
gods,
for example,
share a tremendous number of features in
common.
And so here's,
here's,
here's something to think about.
So there's a reason that people admire
superheroes and it's because they act
out parts of the hero archetype.
That's the technical reason.
They're obviously acting something out
because that's how you can tell they're
superheroes.
They share some set of characteristics
across the set of superheroes that makes
them super heroes.
Now the question might be,
what is the essential element of being a
superhero that makes you a superhero and
the answer,
the way that that was solved
historically is that as a polytheistic
society is developed and that was
usually a consequence of isolated tribes
coming into contact with one another.
They each had their separate deities and
then over the course of time those
deities ward in actual wars with people,
but also conceptually and out of that
polytheistic framework was extracted,
something that was vaguely monotheistic
as all of those cultures came together
to try to determine what their highest
ideals should be,
so that's the god of Gods.
That's a way of thinking about it or the
king of kings.
That's another way of thinking about it
and that's an implicit ideal,
but could make a case.
You tell that to the Hindus.
I mean they got one point,
2 billion people,
or maybe it's one point four now who are
operating in a in a religiously
saturated system that does not conform
to that ideal.
There is no one
topic.
They're still,
they're still associated.
Arguably there's three on top of it all,
but there's still,
um,
there's still an attempt to generate
that polytheistic and to integrate that
polytheistic reality underneath a single
rubric or you have nothing but
continually dissociation of the culture.
And I'm not saying this is necessarily
true
description of what's going on in India
at the moment.
Well,
I'm not,
I'm not saying that this is inevitable
either and there is a tension.
The problem,
the problem Mrs.
Niches,
observation and remember Jay Elliot as
well.
The problem with extracting out the
highest God from the panoply of Gods is
the ideal becomes so abstract that it
disappears.
That's the death of God.
And let us track that phenomena over
multiple cultures,
not it's not something that's unique to
the west.
So the danger of that abstraction is
that it gets too abstract and disappears
and leaves us in this situation that
Douglas just pointed out.
Can I throw this back to the key,
the key issue of Elton John's glass,
which you came up with the other night
because that's something that I wanted
to do.
Add to that.
That would explain why I said Elton
John's class just now.
Oh,
well we came back to this question of
what makes something valuable,
and I used as an example in Vancouver.
I'm one of those nights if I had a glass
here,
which I,
which I said was actually it was the
glass that Elton John used the last time
he played in this theater.
Suddenly it seems to be a more valuable
glass and that Jordan and I argued about
what the status of that value was.
That I don't know where you want.
Well,
it's just one thing in particular,
which is the whole issue of what it is
you give value to and let's let's say
that that glass was demonstrated for
time to having been drunk from by Elton
John at his final concert at work,
no latest farewell tour,
whatever.
So that's already a glass with
something.
Let's say that over the years the whole
attribution of that glass becomes
debatable over a long period of time.
A lot of things are going to have
happened around it and to stretch this
to breaking point,
possibly,
let's say at some point people lose
their lives over whether that is Elton
John's glass or not,
let's say the people to lose blood,
not just say that.
Let's recognize that is the world we're
living in with respect to the
so religions,
so the problem is that we end up,
when we're talking about religion,
when we're talking to the same thing,
when you're talking about land,
you're not just talking about any
inherent worth,
you're talking also about the worth of
things people have given up for this and
so we end up giving the layers of
things.
What knows?
It's more than that.
We inherit more,
more layers if the meaning,
because other people before us have
given that meaning to it so that by the
time you have this object,
it's an object of worth even if it's of
no worth in itself at all because of the
amount of worth of people before you
have given to it.
And that seems to some extent what we're
doing with the religion discussion.
Yes,
yes.
Well,
so,
okay,
so that's,
that's extraordinarily productive.
I think.
So.
See
when you start with the hypothesis of
facts,
then you kind of have to define what a
fact is and so I think the simplest way
of doing that to begin with is that
there's a set of objective facts.
That's the facts about objective
reality.
You can think about that from a
scientific perspective and we're going
to.
We're going to agree that that exists,
although it's very complicated and
difficult to understand that exists has
one set of constraints on what we can do
and what we can do.
That's the objective world.
And then on top of that,
and this is where things get very,
very complicated.
You have this layered system of meaning
which is partly a manifestation of these
layers of the nervous system that I
described,
but also partly a manifestation of those
layers of the nervous system operating
in social space over vast periods of
time.
So that would be the social sociological
agreement.
That's all layered on top of the
objective world and it actually
constitutes part of the.
The Lens through which you view the
world to the degree where you actually
see the layering in the thing,
so like when you go to a museum and you
look at Elvis Presley,
Elvis Presley's guitar,
you don't look at the guitar and think,
that's Elvis Presley's guitar.
That's not how your brain works.
You actually see Elvis Presley's guitar.
It's an active perception,
so it becomes built right into your
nervous system even though the fact that
that is Elvis Presley's guitar and the
reason that that's valuable is because
of a sociological agreement about what
position Elvis Presley occupied in the
dominance hierarchy that we're all part
of.
And so what you see when you look at an
artifact like that is you see a layer of
dominance hierarchy overlaid on top of
an objective reality and that's actually
your phenomenal reality.
Now the thing that's so interesting is
that layer of perception that's
mediating between the facts and you has
a structure and that's the structure
that I've been insisting is a narrative
and I think Sam thinks it's a narrative
too,
because his fundamental ethic is that
you should act in a way which means to
embody a mode of being,
which means to be a personality that
moves us from hell to something
approximating
you haven't what?
I'm struggling to understand what I
don't understand this,
how any of that is a counterpoint to my
concern about religion.
So for it,
because I agree with all that,
I mean there,
there are some caveats.
I would issue,
for instance,
it's quite possible to walk into a
museum,
be shown a guitar,
not,
no,
it's elvis guitar and then
be told it's to Elvis Presley's guitar
and you can see in real time that change
and significant so that you can see the
layers of the perceptual,
the meeting a crew.
You might actually not even kidding,
you might know it.
Who else Elvis Presley is and not care.
Right?
So there are many different,
uh,
things on,
on,
on the menu here as opposed to just
beholding Austrac,
Elvis,
Presley's guitar,
and the,
and the same is true of the Jesus story
or anything else that,
that you can find layers of engagement
with it,
that they may be more and less useful.
My fundamental concern is that the way
you are tending to dignify the religious
subset of stories as being fun,
foundational,
necessary,
it just,
we criticized at our peril,
is giving people license to believe
things that they clearly shouldn't
believe.
Things that are intrinsically divisive
in intrinsically less than optimal as
far as organizing and individual human
life.
We can do better than Christianity on
almost every question,
but with the possible exception of
building churches.
Okay,
so the first thing is,
the first thing is that I deeply agree
with you that that mechanism can go
wrong.
Okay,
so you have the objective world and it's
one set of constraints and then you have
this interpretive structure.
And I'm not saying that that
interpretive structure is infallible.
It clearly isn't,
and neither is the process that gives
rise to it.
You see this,
for example,
in conditions like manic depressive
disorder with religious delusions or
schizophrenia,
you see what you see in those situations
is a pathologization of that overlay of
meaning that can clearly.
Okay,
now the question is what do we do about
that?
How do we keep those perceptual
structures which are somewhat arbitrary?
How do we keep them functional,
and this is I think where your
discussion of rationality is so
important,
particularly when you say rationality is
what enables us to establish what will
you agree on in our shared reality.
Okay,
so so imagine this,
so part of the way you orient yourself
in the world of facts,
objective facts is through your senses,
so you basically have five dimensions of
triangulation,
so to speak,
to help you determine what's there in
the objective world,
and then you have this multilayer
structure that's partly biological and
partly socio culture,
that cultural that enables you to
distill that,
but it can go astray part because it
ages and becomes archaic,
which is an and demented for that
matter,
which is partly your objection to the
fundamentalist types.
This has been known for a very long time
that this sort of thing happens.
So what we do,
the way we solved that,
we have a solution to that.
So partly the way we solve that is
through articulated discourse,
right?
Because you have a way of looking at the
world and I have a way of looking at the
world and we have to occupy the same
space.
So you're probably wrong about some
things and I'm probably wrong about some
things and hopefully if we we can sort
out the differences and make things more
stable
and I would put rationality right in
that place.
That's by rationality is prime.
Right?
The problem.
Fair enough.
But,
but there's a problem with that too.
And I see all the times we've talked so
far,
you've been,
I would say the Avatar of a scientific
viewpoint.
And I'd been cast,
let's say as the Avatar of a religious
viewpoint,
but I've actually thought this through
scientifically a lot and I can make a
biological argument for all of this and
a developmental argument.
So it isn't only rationality that does
this.
So this is what the thing that was so
cool about studying,
for example,
John Piaget,
because one of the things piaget pointed
out is that children engage in
negotiation it,
they negotiate the rep,
they reality just like adults do,
but they don't do it only through
articulated speech and neither do adults
with children do is they get together
and play and this is why play is so
important for children that starts to
happen when there were about three years
of all because they can look outside
their own idiosyncratic perspective at
three and they can start to take someone
else's view point into consideration,
which is what you have to do if you're
going to play.
And then what children do is they invent
little fictional realities.
That's what they do when they're
pretending.
And so they assigned each other roles
and they assigned a plot and a drama to
the,
to the pretend play and then they act it
out.
And in that action they bring themselves
into harmonious union.
Right?
Which is the act of generating a game
that everyone wants to play.
And Piaget's observation was,
and this is Nietzschean observation as
well,
but the morality that characterizes
society isn't rationality top down,
although it's partly that it's also
interactions that are,
say,
play based and bought them up,
and that's actually how it evolved to
begin with because animals generate
societies that are functional,
but they don't do it through
rationality.
They can't because they don't have
rationality,
they don't have articulated speech.
They have something like an embodied
game.
Now what happens,
and this is a Nietzschean observation,
he's the first person I learned this
from,
is our morality emerged from the bottom
up through through thousands,
hundreds of thousands of years have
shared games,
let's say at the end,
the interweaving of those shared games
into something approximating a morality
that we could all live within
peacefully.
That happened bottom up and then what
happened was because we didn't know the
mechanism behind that because it's
instantiated in our nervous system
invisibly.
We watched ourselves act,
which is what we do,
and then we told stories about that
because that's what we do when we watch
yourself act,
and then we encapsulated the morality
that evolved in the stories and that's
the religious essence of the story.
Ten seconds
we have to pivot to Douglas for a a,
an important question,
but I would just say in response to
that,
Jordan,
I don't
disagree with much of consequence in
that.
My concern however,
is that there is.
There's a,
there's a reason why we differentiate
childhood from adulthood and all of us
are stunted to some degree or another in
a fairly perverse childhood.
And the reason,
I mean what,
what we,
what we confront now is a world largely
populated by dangerous children,
right?
Who are in their fifth and sixth decade
of life.
I mean running by populated and run by.
Yes,
and,
and it's so real and if anything
typifies the childhood of our species,
in my view,
it is his religious orthodoxy and in so
far as we're breaking free of the
orthodoxy part and getting something
that's more scalable and,
and,
and can survive a more pluralistic and
cosmopolitan world.
It is because it is being winnowed at
every point by rationality.
And I think that that at some point we
could have a fully defensible,
rational honoring of,
of many of the things you think are,
are essential like the power of story,
the power of ritual or the power of,
of,
of art that is focused on some sacred
purpose.
Uh,
and the question is how to get there,
right?
We have a point of order.
That's one question,
but,
uh,
I want to hand over to the audience for
q and a and a for a couple of minutes.
I've had a sign being waved at me saying
q and a and really should have been
signed.
So I think what's gonna happen is we're
going to use your computer.
We're going to,
we're going to ask the audience first.
I think that was what we decided and I
guess you guys get to vote by noise.
There's an inflection point here.
We can do one of two things and I'll
let.
I'll let the first people yell and then
the second people yell,
but the question is we can either
continue the discussion or we can stop
and go to q and a.
So the first thing we'll do is say,
okay,
how many of you would like us to stop
and go to q and a?
Okay.
Second,
second question.
How many of you would like us to
continue with the discussion?
That's,
that's a successful vote.
Do I want to go?
I'm going to see is the floor.
I want to ask a question to both of you.
It's about the three of us,
but I think it's more about the two of
you.
Each of us to one or another degree has
been described as a gateway drug to the
alt right.
We've been attacked by,
by people left of center as somehow
inspiring or pandering to right of
center and in many cases,
far right of center ideas and,
and,
and ethical
and pseudo ethical commitments.
Uh,
I'm wondering.
Yeah,
I'm wondering,
I'm wondering if we can steal man,
the concerns that people have with us
for a few minutes before addressing the
boy.
How do you,
how do you view this,
this reaction to your work and.
Well,
I'm happy to do that first.
Can I just say before I do that was
going to say if we were going to go to
audience Qa,
I understand it was reminded today that
there's still a blasphemy law and
Ireland.
Ah.
Well am I right on that?
I,
I wait the police.
I'm right on time.
Yeah.
In which case can I just say that I'm
not going to be happy if we leave the
stage tonight in handcuffs.
I have not both committed last,
right?
Yeah.
And if Jordan would make hypergrid that
to do that in private,
we could make it a full house.
I really do think we should be last
semester.
I think I must have done that already,
but I'll have to go to the tape on that.
Um,
so.
Well,
here's the thing,
we've all had similar experiences on
that and there are a number of people in
our friends and colleagues.
Perhaps you might say you've had it as
well.
Um,
and I think what's happening at the
moment is that there's a set of trip
wires that have been put across the
culture and for a long time,
if you went across these trip wires,
you died reputationally speaking because
of the nature of the media,
new media,
among other things that sudden death
isn't possible anymore.
Or this is not always possible.
Right?
So for instance,
if the New York Times says that Jordan
is a,
you know,
sort of leading member of the Ku Klux
Klan,
it's not just that people don't believe
the New York Times anymore,
it's that they can go and find out for
themselves that this is a lie.
And that's the fundamental difference.
And it means that people are surviving
the trip wire experience.
But there's a whole set of these trip
wires.
And I think they've been,
they've been planted very strangely
among other things.
I mean,
the one I tripped on was Islam one think
to an extent.
It was the one you tripped on Jordan.
It was more to do with farms and
pronouns was the first one.
The Great.
The great thing about this,
by the way,
is there,
once you survived the first trip wire,
you know,
my kids,
they sort of merrily jump along in no
man's land,
land
live on ied after ied.
And strangely I'm still here.
You said steal.
Amanda.
Here's what I think is probably
happening.
There was a fear that in this realm of
uncertain values,
which we might concede at any rate that
we're in a,
there is only one thing we all agree on,
but one thing we all agree on is we
mustn't become Nazis.
Okay?
Broadly speaking,
that's the basis of our face.
It's the only bit of history anyone
knows and they don't even know it.
So they think they're all over the
Hitler thing.
Alright?
Haven't got a clue.
Most of them all they know is Hitler was
a bad person.
This is why,
by the way,
anyone anyone doesn't like in politics
is Hitler like George w Dot Bush,
Hitler.
If you had any sense of historical
reference,
you might say Henry,
the fifth domineering father who
shadowed you had to step out of,
for instance,
but there Henry,
the fifth myth knows about that.
So it's everything's Hitler.
So if we agree that the one thing we're
all meant to do is not become Nazis.
You build these incredibly deep trenches
around anything you think could be
something that would lead us back to
that.
The problem is is that people who have
done that trench building include people
who are doing it for their own personal
political game,
so they build a set of trenches around
their political views and they say,
if you come near this and you've gotten
into that trench and there were Nazi.
Some of it is for short term convenience
and I've no doubt that some of it is
sincere,
but the amount of the amount of lying
about it makes me doubt that last bit,
and let me add one other thing to that.
One of the books I recommend people read
most to do with politics.
There's a brilliant book by Paul Berman
who I think you know as well go power
and the idealists.
It has,
by the way,
the worst subtitle of any book.
It's called power and the idealist.
The strange passion of Jasko Fisher.
Now distinguished left wing German
politician,
though he is a.
it's not,
it doesn't,
it doesn't leap off the shelf.
Anyhow,
the strange passion of Jasko Fisher is
an amazing book which I wish was taught
in schools because he describes in this
book how this group of Germans who grew
up in the 19 fifties had one but one
name was.
We're not going to become like our
parents.
Okay.
If they think it's enough to orient
their politics around what happened,
uh,
the green movement melds with the part
of the German left,
a whole set of things happen.
They ended up agreeing with the PLO and
the hijackings in the late sixties and
early seventies.
And before you know it,
one of your fishes housemates is on the
plane as it's on the tarmac and he's
separating out the Jews.
And the Non Jews,
we've it again,
the one thing we are meant not to become
was the people standing on the ramp
seeing that way that way.
And we did it.
We went all the way around.
So there's something about this that I
just wish was better known,
but he's not as damn easiest.
All that.
Like your enemies don't come with Jack
boots and swastikas like this.
It's just not that easy.
No,
they live inside you.
Right?
That's really the case.
So let me try this steel manifold.
Okay.
So.
So the first thing that people assume
about me is that I'm no fan of the
radical left.
And that's absolutely.
And that's absolutely true.
I am no fan of
the radical left.
How narrowly,
because there's a variety of reasons,
but it's primarily because I believe
that the radical left airs in insisting
had every possible opportunity that the
proper defining characteristic of each
individual is their group membership.
I think that that's you and you do have
a group membership.
In fact,
you have a whole plethora of them which
makes things quite complicated as the
intersection list have already figured
out.
But whenever someone brings a primary
orientation to the world that is group
centered rather than individual
centered,
I think they've already made a
catastrophic mistake.
And so I don't approve of the.
It's now I don't approve of left wing
collectivist and I don't approve of
right wing collectivist,
but the right wing collectivist haven't
overrun the universities and the lifting
collected as so.
So that's a distinct difference.
Now
leftwing collectivists enjoy acquiring a
certain linguistic hegemony because they
know that that's part of the way they
can win the battle and that's what they
were trying to do when they pass
compelled speech legislation in Canada
as far as I was concerned.
So I made a video saying I'm not going
to abide by that because I'm not using
the reprehensible linguistic maneuvers
of collectivists who I detest.
So now when I did that,
you see it was a very strange thing for
a Canadian to do because Canadians don't
do that partly because Canada works just
fine.
And so nobody comes up and says waves
the flag saying,
look,
we're,
we're wandering off a dangerous cliff
here.
And so then if someone does stand up and
say that,
then the first thing that all the other
Canadians think and should think is that
there's something wrong with that person
and that would be me.
So then the question would be,
well,
what variety of things could be wrong
with Dr Peterson?
That's a very long list,
but the ones that might actually at
better subtitled the title.
So.
So what happened was I objected
to the radical left.
That was my perspective,
but the people who objected to me or who
were even critical of mere curious about
me thought,
okay,
well if Peterson isn't part of the left,
then where the hell is he announcer
could be anywhere on the political
spectrum including Nazi.
And of course that's hypothetically
true.
And if I was a Nazi then that would be
really useful for all the radical
leftists.
Because if you're a Nazi,
as Douglas has already pointed out,
we've already decided that you're a bad
person.
And if I was a bad person then no one
would have to listen to me.
And so it was in the interests of the
radicals who I was just whose positions
I was disputing to cast me as a Nazi,
but it was also a reasonable cognitive
maneuver because there was some
possibility,
although it's infinitesimal,
given the tiny proportion of actual
Nazis in our society that I would in
fact be one and have gotten away with
hiding that at two major universities
for 25 years.
And also
awesome
at that point I had 250 hours of my
lectures on youtube,
which was basically every word in
essence that I ever uttered to a student
since 1993.
And a huge part of that actually
consisted of very trenchant criticisms
of Nazis.
So it was difficult to pin that on me.
So,
so,
but to give my critics credit,
they had their reason for vilifying me.
And the reason was if you object,
you might be a villain.
Okay.
So,
so that's,
that's steel man.
Number one.
I'm not at least the kind of villain
they think I am,
although I might be some other kind of
villain altogether.
So then the next steel man issue is the
left has a place.
Okay,
so why?
Well,
here's why.
In order to act properly in the world,
you have to do things.
Everyone agrees on that and to do things
you have to do them.
In the social world,
you have to cooperate and compete with
other people.
And when you cooperate and compete with
other people in the service of valid
goals,
valuable goals,
productive goals,
you produce hierarchies,
you produce hierarchies of competence
and hierarchies of power.
Those aren't exactly the same thing,
but either way you produce hierarchies,
hierarchies,
dispossessed people.
They dispossessed people because the
spoils go to a few.
That's the problem of the unequal
distribution of wealth.
And because in any hierarchy of
competence,
a disproportionate number of a small
number of people do most of the creative
work.
And these are iron clad laws.
Okay?
So the problem with higher hierarchies
are necessary,
but the problem with hierarchies as they
produce disposition and the left in
principal speaks for the dispossessed
and someone has to speak for the
dispossessed.
And so when the left,
he's looking at me and they say,
well,
Dr Peterson is always speaking about the
necessity of hierarchies and how can we
be sure that he's not trying to justify
them in their current position and
obscure the fact that they tend towards
tyranny and deception,
which they clearly do.
How do we know that he's just not
reifying the present power structure for
his own aims and why should we trust
them?
And that's a perfectly valid objection.
Now I believe it happens to be wrong
because I understand the downside of
hierarchies in and I also think I
understand how to go about rectifying
that,
but that's why they're objecting in so
far as they don't as the.
Insofar as they're playing a straight
political game and not ideological form
of grandiosity.
Grandiosity.
So there's one of the thing in this
which is worth mentioning,
which is the perception is that the,
the,
as it were,
aside from,
let's say this is the center of the
political access and going to have to do
this for you.
But okay,
that's the right.
The presumption is that the,
it's just a cliff,
like if you start by saying,
I don't know,
I think people should pay some taxes or
whatever,
right?
You have that and you just go like that
and then it's not Susan.
Right.
And
it's a really weird thing that is
discussed because all of this look at
all of this is just the footnote still
the 20th century and we're still trying
to work out what happened and why and we
don't know.
And in the history books,
the period we're living,
it will be the post Holocaust,
post World War Two posts,
ghoulag world when they were still
trying to sort out what happened behind
the crime scene tape.
Okay.
So on the left there's a very
interesting thing which is that you can
go pretty much all the way like this and
first of all there's not a very wide
recognition that you had the gulag not.
There's not very much known about that.
People don't read,
they don't read it.
So.
So you can go pretty far left.
You just hit the vegans.
But there's actually,
you might be like radical
your fan this.
Okay.
So the problem is not just,
they don't know what happened on that
side,
but it's worse than that.
There was a,
there was a young girl,
a commentator on the TV and the London a
couple of mornings ago arguing about
trump and so on is a usual,
not very enlightening discussion.
He's arguing with Piers Morgan and she
says,
you,
you keep on saying,
I'm a supporter of Barack Obama.
I mean,
I'm a communist.
She said,
I'm literally a communist thought if
this girl had said you knew you should
be more careful.
I'm literally a fascist,
you know?
Yeah.
By the way,
I did that one carefully on that.
No,
I'm,
I'm alive to Youtube New York Times
headline.
Yeah,
exactly.
Little Fascist.
But if he's got,
not everyone is busy searching around,
like in Canada,
the one of the big discussion forums,
uh,
the human rights commissions found that
there were like 11 people on this Neo
Nazi forum and it turned out half of
them were working for the Canadian
government trying to find me or not.
Canadian government constituted 50
percent of the Neo Nazis in Canada.
They're scurrying around looking for the
Nazis like this,
and on the other side it's like
mainstream or the television.
Yeah,
I'm a communist.
I'd love to go through that again.
So here,
here's another problem.
This is a really interesting problem.
Okay,
so you brought up two things and one is
no one knows about what happened in
Mao's China or what happened in the
Soviet Union,
which is absolutely appalling because we
should all know that.
And so there's obviously a cliff on the
left side.
Now I would say actually there is the
possibility that as you move farther out
on each end of the political spectrum,
the rate at which you deteriorate
accelerate.
So it's not linear.
I think that's possible.
But having said that,
that's also the case on the left.
Now,
one of the things we could say is,
well those idiot leftists should get
their house in order because they won't
differentiate themselves from their
radical brethren.
Okay,
so now we might ask,
well why?
We might ask two things.
Why and whose problem is that exactly.
Okay.
So the first issue of why is,
well,
people who are left leaning have a hard
time drawing boundaries.
That's what makes them left leaning and
I mean this technically because left
leaning,
people are high in openness to
experience which is a creativity trait.
So they like information flow and they
don't like borders between things and
they tend to be low in orderliness.
So disorder doesn't discuss an upset.
Okay.
So they can't draw boundaries and that's
why they're on the left.
But boundaries have their problems.
So there's some utility in people who
don't like them.
Okay.
But the second problem is,
and this isn't a problem that's only
Germane to the left,
it's the problem of the dam 20th
century.
It's like okay,
when does the left go too far?
And the answer is nobody knows.
Like with the right wingers,
you can tell man,
it's like they make a claim of ethnic or
racial superiority.
It's like box Nazi,
right?
And then you can see that this happens
because even back in the seventies when
William f Buckley was sort of a leading
conservative,
he put a box around the Ku Klux Klan.
And the John Birch types and he said,
I'm not you,
but none of that's happening on the
left.
Okay,
why?
Well,
they say,
well,
we stand for diversity.
It's like,
well,
everyone likes diversity and well,
what about inclusivity?
Damn right,
man.
Let's include some people.
Well,
what about,
what about equality?
That'd be good.
Let's have so many quality.
It's like,
okay,
well how he quality.
Exactly.
Well then it's gradations,
right?
Well,
equality of opportunity.
Damn straight.
Equality of outcome.
Sounds good.
How about no under no circumstances
whatsoever,
but you know I can
man.
You get somebody,
you get somebody saying race or
ethnicity.
Group member x is detestable because of
their group identity and you think evil
Nazi,
but then you see someone saying,
well I just wish that everybody could
have an equal outcome.
What are you going to do?
You're going to are going to punch them.
It's what you're supposed to do with
Nazis.
No,
you're not.
You're going to take hold.
That's a pretty nice person.
And it's like,
just because you're nice doesn't mean
you're good.
And just because you stand for equality
of outcome doesn't mean
right,
but the thing is
complex technical problem,
right?
Because it looks like you need a
multivariate equation to define
pathology on the left,
it's like,
well,
if you believe this and this and this in
and to disproportionately,
then we have to put a box around you.
But it's not like someone wears a symbol
on their damn shirt or tattooed onto
their face that enables you to identify
them.
So we have a real structural problem
here.
We don't know how to box in pathology on
the left.
No one knows,
including the moderate leftist,
but none of us know.
An additional problem is that any of
these issues may not have a solution
that we can happily live with.
Right?
So it'd be takes it.
Let's sharpen this up.
And this was more in the interest of
steel manning our critics.
You take a problem like immigration
right now,
the,
the intuition that's driving the left.
Let's take the extreme case of an open
borders ethic.
Borders are illegitimate.
Borders are a principal,
a of of selfishness and xenophobia and
and unearned privilege,
right?
None of us can take credit for the fact
that we were born into the societies
were born into a and yet we have all of
the advantages of having been born there
and so it is with with all of you and
the weird.
None of us are currently living through
the civil war in Syria now and that's a
good thing for all of us.
And so the concern here is that the
moment you say,
well,
immigration is potentially a problem,
right?
Immigrate.
We can't just throw open the borders to
all of humanity because what would
happen,
what would happen is people would
continue to cross those borders until
the,
the level of,
of,
of wellbeing in,
in the developed world diminished so
much that there was no reason to cross
the borders anymore.
Right?
It would be,
they would just say some principle of
Osmosis.
Right?
So it's even.
It's even worse than that,
but the concern is that this is
totally ethically speaking,
this is a totally illegitimate situation
and to shine a bright enough light on
any particular story in Syria,
say,
I mean you just give me the right family
with children and I learned enough about
them and their plight and I recognize
within 30 seconds that if I were them,
I would be desperate to get to Dublin or
New York or San Francisco or anywhere
but Syria.
Right?
And it seems like a completely,
uh,
it seems evil to in any way perpetuate
this lottery where you pulled a bad
ticket and sorry,
that's.
This defines the rest of your life and
the lives of your children.
And we,
and,
and it,
there is no bright line where any of us,
you know,
well,
meaning people,
wherever we are in the political
spectrum or wherever we are in any other
question,
there's no bright line where we can say,
Aha,
that's exactly the,
as the solution that we know is ethical,
that we know we can defend against all
comers and it can survive every test of
narrative.
It just goes straight to the power of
stories.
You tell it,
you tell people a compelling enough
story about one little girl and it
changes.
Policy isn't not what happened to
Angola.
Merkel,
she was faced with one,
one d denied refugee and all of a sudden
the policy for Europe changed.
Uh,
and so this is,
again,
this is a,
I'm not saying there's a solution to
this,
but this is the fear,
the fear that there's,
there's an,
there's an imputation of callousness on
the part of.
I'm speaking specifically to you
Douglas,
because it's been your issue more than
ours.
How callous must you be to be worrying
about immigration?
And that's that.
That's obviously there's a counter
argument from the right side,
but there is a,
there's an ethical core to it that is,
it's difficult to dismiss.
And this is something which,
I mean it's not just that issues almost
every issue.
We were talking a bit about this dinner
that we seem to be,
well,
we just aren't ready for the
communications age women and we're just
not ready for.
Our brains are not yet able to cope.
Let me give you an example.
Uh,
the notion of private and public speech
that's just basically evaporated so that
if you,
this is the problem,
try out an idea with your friends.
Just throw around an idea.
We've all done it for around ideas with
your friends.
If even one person is videoing it and
might post it,
this is what is the world.
We're all in it.
It's too dangerous to try things out
for.
Most people have no borders and
so this is it.
So we are always vulnerable that are,
for instance,
most people in Europe,
one borders.
I mean like overwhelming majority in
every country want there to be borders,
but if you show them footage of somebody
being turned away at the border that
morning,
there's like,
we don't know what to do with it.
We,
we,
we have abstract principles we need to
abide by.
We want to abide by everybody wants to
buy,
but we don't know what to do in this
precisely this era.
And I think we've just got to,
among other things,
work and all sorts of ways to find ways
to think about this.
At a deeper than the ones we've managed
so far,
one of them,
yes,
is to cope with the idea of being
unbelievable luck,
but we've got unbelievable luck and then
the questions from that.
If I'm lucky,
what am I,
what am I priorities?
What am my obligation?
What am I lucky?
What are my obligations?
And some people say,
my obligation is to share my home with
the rest of the world.
In fact,
it's not that it's worse than that
because it's because I know lots of
people who've taken in a refugee and
things like that.
Okay.
And I have unbelievable admiration for
them.
That's really working the walk,
but it's a different thing
called your bluff when you said,
I don't see you taking in refugees into
your home.
And they said,
oh actually there's one of the.
I always wanted to turn up to their
houses with some refugees.
Say I've got yours and go there also
aren't 50 in the living room.
Exactly.
So,
so,
so let's,
let's,
let's elaborate on this a bit more.
Okay.
So the issue is borders exclude,
right?
That's a postmodern proposition,
or maybe you can take that even further
than borders,
excluding privileged those within the
borders.
It's like,
yes.
Okay,
so let's take that seriously.
Now I'm part of this.
Seriousness is poor.
Innocent children are hurt at borders.
That happens all the time.
Okay?
The question is,
are you willing to give up the borders?
Now,
let's think about what borders are.
Your skin is a border,
okay,
and your prejudice in protection of your
skin.
For example,
you won't just sleep with anyone.
You reserve the right to keep that
border in tact,
right?
And to be choosy about the manner in
which it's broached,
you're,
you likely have a bedroom.
It probably has walls.
You have clothing,
you have a house,
you have a town,
you have a state,
you have a country,
and those are all borders.
It's borders within borders,
within borders,
without borders,
and you need those borders because
otherwise you will die,
so we could not be too hypocritical
about the damn borders is like we don't
know how to organize fragile things
without putting boundaries around them.
When you see that in Genesis,
right?
As soon as people realize that I'm
sneaking in little religion here in
case,
as soon as people realize they become
self conscious,
they wake
up and realize their vulnerability.
The first thing they do is manufacturer
a border between them and the world and
we need borders between us and the world
and we pay a bloody price for borders
and I say those words very carefully.
We play.
Pay a bloody price for borders and it's
often in the price of other people's
blood and so then the question might be,
well,
how should you conduct yourself
ethically in a world where other people
are paying in blood for your borders?
And the answer that I've been trying to
communicate to people is get your damn
house in order.
As much responsibility as you can,
act as effectively as you can as an
individual in the world.
Because then you can justify your
privilege.
You can justify your luck and your good
fortune and maybe within the confines of
your border you can be more productive
and useful than you would be in the
absolute absence of borders altogether.
And it seems to me that that's the case
and then we have to have a discussion.
Okay,
the left doesn't like borders and the
right is more fond of them and they're
both right.
And so because we don't know how strict
the borders should be,
all how permeable it should be.
It shouldn't be absolute,
so nothing moves between borders and
everything dies them.
But if the borders disappeared then we
can't survive.
So we have to have a discussion about
borders all the time.
And that's partly that.
It's partly what we're doing here.
We have to be more sophisticated
things.
Very few people end up getting held
accountable for their own use in this
matter as an amongst so many others.
There's an enormous amount to gain by
saying something that's wrong and
there's very little to gain by saying
something is right on this.
I mean you just.
Just a world of suffering and look
problem with this.
I mean this is,
this is your,
this is your area of politics more than
it is mine.
But these lines that are being put down
on the left at the moment of which this
is one,
these other ones that are now coming up.
I mean you see today's one,
you can't act a role that you're on your
hands.
You can't pretend to be someone else.
Like this is a brand new rule.
I'm talking about a Scarlett Johansson
who was cast in the film as a trans
for transgender woman.
I think Amanda Woman,
it might've been the other way around,
but it's scarcely matters.
Oh,
it matches.
That's your fascist movements.
That's my privilege.
Interesting.
Because that's actually a boundary to.
That's actually a border to it.
So it's another case where these things
reverse in a perverse manner.
Like where did that one
come from?
Yeah,
well it probably came from the west
coast.
Yeah,
yeah.
It,
it seems to me that we need to somehow
get comfortable with the increasingly
public moments of,
of uncertainty on topics like this
because so much of so much of safety and
reputational safety,
as you were just alluding,
is predicated in the public sphere in
either pretending to be certain or,
or false sleeping certain on a safe
answer,
a safe and wrong answer to a
complicated.
All
part of this is,
is,
um,
the pathology of basal instinct.
And so because the rule now is if I feel
sorry for you,
I'm good.
Right?
And so,
so let's say there's a complex situation
that requires a tremendous amount of
adult cognitive computation to solve,
like what do we do about the borders?
Because tearing them down is not the
answer.
Well,
the person who stands up and says,
well,
I see someone who's hurt by a border and
I feel empathy for them.
Then immediately says,
therefore I'm good,
which isn't so bad,
but therefore I'm also morally superior
to you.
And this is.
This is one of the true pathologies of
the empathic collectivists is that they
presume that they reflects of empathy,
marks them out as morally superior,
and that's appalling because part of it
is a.
it's too easy.
Just because I feel sorry for you.
It doesn't mean I'm good partly because
I can feel so sorry for you that I'm
actually harmful to you and that's what
happens in the case of over protective
parents,
for example,
so we know perfectly well
that empathy is not an untrammeled moral
virtue.
It has to be tempered by other virtues
and carefully tempered by other virtues
and so we have to stop allowing in our
public discourse the unquestioned
assumption that just because I manifest
more pity in the moment than you do that
I'm somehow morally superior
individually.
In fact,
not only do we have to question that,
we fact have to.
We have to deeply question it and say,
what makes you think that you're.
That you're just not taking things too
far right there because there's just as
much error on the side of too much
empathy as there is on the side of too
little empathy and that's a hard thing
for everyone to learn because empathy
feels so good.
Like if you feel mercy towards us
suffering child,
it's like that is kind of an indication
that you're an ethical person,
but that's not the basis for complex and
sophisticated foreign policy.
No,
it isn't because
it
we know our empathy diminishes it almost
linear way with the numbers of people to
empathize with.
Right?
So how we spoke about this one night in
Vancouver,
but this has been tested.
Where did you tell someone about the
plight of one little girl?
You will elicit the maximum empathic
response and the Mat.
The maximum of an altruistic response
that they'll get the most amount of
money they're going to give to any cause
to one compelling story to save one
little boy or girl,
but if you start adding boys and girls
to the to the one keeping the one the
same,
people's empathy degrades and their
actual at their altruism degrees.
So.
So empathy is non quantitative almost by
definition.
Yeah.
It's also partly because in your life if
you see a person in trouble,
something,
but if you see 100 million people in
trouble,
what you should probably do at least to
begin with is run and what are you going
to do it?
Maybe you could give a thousand dollars
to one person,
but if you divided that up among a
million,
all of that would happen.
Would you?
Would you wouldn't be have.
You would have no money and they
wouldn't be any better off.
But,
but,
but this is just say that so much of of
moral progress today entails unhooking
from the highly salient empathy driving
story and connecting with the actual
quantitative reality to learn that it's
500,000
people dying every year from heart
disease or whatever it is,
or there's,
there's this is 500,000
people dying for this family.
The fact that that that can't be made
sexy for,
for our news cycle,
right?
The fact that we lose attention is
something we have to figure out how to
and also it can.
It's very interestingly akin to your
objection that you raised before is that
there are,
there are adult forms of solving
problems that aren't akin to children's
play,
which is something by the way,
I agree with because I don't think that
the manner in which children organized
the world is the end of the way that
things should be organized.
It's the basis for some of the
organization,
but this is akin to the same issue,
is that the basal motivational
responses,
the emotional response is no matter how
well meaning aren't sufficient
conceptual sophistication to deal with
incredibly elaborate and complex systems
and then you have another problem too,
is that,
well,
that's really troublesome for people
because they want to do the right thing
globally and then you tell them,
look,
you don't know anything.
You don't know how to take this insanely
complicated system that we have and
improve it,
and just because you're feeling pity
doesn't mean that you're an expert in
the retooling of hydroelectric systems.
For example,
and this one has one straightforward way
to do that.
I mean,
given the example,
there's a Kurdish demographer who lives,
who's Swedish citizen now who cited this
fact that it costs the same amount one
refugee and keep them in Sweden as it
does to look after 100 refugees in
Jordan,
Turkey or Lebanon.
Okay?
So the obvious thing from that,
if you say,
look,
it's madness
to be,
for instance,
bringing in thousands of refugees to
Sweden.
You could be looking after hundreds of
thousands of people in the region.
Why is that still a tainted argument is
because people aren't sure.
You're not going to smuggle in racism.
That's what I think.
Are you sure you're not just coming up
with this democracy stuff in order like
you're smuggling in Hitler just typed
smuggling Jesus.
You're going to start with NGO figures
and before we know it,
it's outfits.
That's what they think.
But here's the thing.
This is the shortcut solution to
answering.
Almost every single one of these
problems is assume that your
interlocutor has good motives,
that they are being on this in the way
that they're looking at it
and that's when I say comments about
that.
Okay,
so
this is something I deal with in my
clinical practice all the time.
Okay.
So imagine that you're naive and then
what you are when you're naive as
someone who thinks you trust people
because you think everybody has good
motivations,
which is some sense with douglass is a
recommended it and I'd say,
well that's just naive.
It's like,
just wait a second though because here's
the developmental pathway.
First year naive and you trust everyone
and then someone cuts you off at the
knees or multiple people do,
or maybe you cut yourself off at the
knees because you trusted yourself too
much and you didn't take into account
the malevolence that lurks in your heart
and the hearts of others and so that you
get traumatized by betrayal and then you
become cynical and you think,
Jesus,
I'm a lot smarter now that I'm cynical
and you are because cynical is actually
a move up on naive,
but it's not the last move.
The last move is to transcend cynicism
and to say that even though I know that
there are just as many snakes in your
heart as there are in my heart,
I'm going to hold out my hand in trust
because that's the best way to elevate
both of us.
That is the prerequisite for a sensitive
discussion to concede that
going on about our stuff along this to
concede that it's not between good and
evil but between competing virtues.
But when it comes to something like the
board has discussion,
you're dealing with justice and mercy.
You can not only be driven by one of
those virtues,
mercy itself will lead you to hell.
Justice on its own wind unseeing can
lead you to hell.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
Well,
and so this also,
and we're running very short on time
here,
so we should have think this is also why
your emphasis on truth and the emphasis
on truth is so absolutely important
because you and I obviously differ in on
a variety of different things and,
and uh,
as Douglas does with both of us.
But you know,
that doesn't mean.
That doesn't mean that I think that
you're a bad person.
I don't think that actually what I,
what I think and what I fervently hope
is that some of the things that you
think are wrong actually turn out to be
right in a way that would extremely
helpful to me at everyone.
I know if I incorporated them.
Like I really hope that because I'd
rather not be stupid and wrong if I
could help it because then I don't have
to wander into a pit.
And so I'm hoping that if,
if we can have a genuine dialogue and we
can tell each other the truth,
which is the crucial issue here,
then I can find out what you know that I
don't know and that'll make me stronger
and it will fortify everyone around me
and that's the basis for the right and
responsibility of free speech,
right?
You have the right of free speech,
but that's so that you can be a
responsible bearer of free speech so
that you can say the truth so that you
can set the world right in,
adjust the hierarchies and make sure the
borders are properly functional and so
that we can keep this thing going
properly and that is all dependent,
at least in part,
in large part on the truth.
But also to some degree on this faculty
that you described is rational because
we're engaged in Iraq.
I know rationality isn't denounced that
that's my sense,
you know,
but it's certainly an adult form of
communication and definitely the
prerequisite to a discussion like this,
which seems to be highly useful and
which I'm so happy that you're all
willing to participate in how strangely,
how strange that is not.
Yes.
Well we've been showing various cards
that had diminishing increments of time
and now they have just stopped showing
us car.
It's because we're totally
encourageable.
But uh,
yeah.
I just want to reiterate what,
what Jordan's just said there are.
You all really are the occasion for this
conversation.
Even though you are,
are in the audience and we're on stage.
We very much feel that this conversation
is with all of you and we know the
conversation continues in your lives and
it,
again,
it's just a tremendous honor to show up
and,
and meet all of you in this space.
And so thank you for that.
I want to,
I want to thank.
I want to thank both of these men.
We,
we've never gotten together before like
this and it's really,
it's a.
it's a great pleasure to be confronted
and cajoled and ate your company.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you all very much.